نحن الان في ميناء غزه الميناء التي دمرها
الاحتلال لكن ليس لرصد الدمار هذه المره
لرصد احدى سبل الحياه بعد ان باتت الملاذ
الوحيد لكثير من العائلات بعد ان انقطعت
السبل بهم
وبذوق هذه العائلات ولكثير من عائلات
اهالي قطاع غزه اليهود ايش بعد امرار
بيسمحوا لنا نطلع برا المينا بس ايش لا
يعني امطار قليله برا المينا احنا ايش
اللي طلعنا هيك لا بجيبوا لنا لا طحين ولا
اكل ولا شرب عايشين على ابو جلمبو وعايشين
اذا بصد لنا سمكه زي هيك سمك بس هي اللي
عايشين عليه لا في خبز ولا اكل عننا قالوا
بدهم يوصلوا معونات ومش عارف ايش وبدهم
يغرقوا غزه وبدهم
يضبطوا ولا وصلنا شي بالشاطئ كله من عنده
ولا وصلنا شيء ولا مركب حديث خله عننا ولا
مركب صير الدمار اللي
فيدمر حسك تدمر واحنا بنيجي هنا كل يومص
سمك عشان ما في طحين ولا في مساعدات ولا
في شي
ناكله يحاول المواطنون الاحتياج من هذه
الميناء رغم الدمار الكبير وما حل بها
ورغم القصف المستمر ما بين فينه واخرى من
زوارق قوات الاحتلال من ميناء غزه اسماعيل
الغول قناه
الجزيره